[Music]
welcome everybody for the Thursday
evening current games classmen on the
currently what's going on a wooden block
chest and while tournaments as you know
he can't get in council then postponed
but I've had this game from a woman's
Grand Prix tournament in Lausanne that
is going on right now and this again is
a Russian Grand Master gory octina
alexandra garage Cena against Juventud
they actually play the World
Championship match recently in Shanghai
and Vladivostok and it was epic match
one of the best matches in history at
least for the Women's World Championship
Jim and Jim was leading by one point
garage Tina won the last game on demand
with white and then with white or black
I'm not sure she won the game she
equalized the match forced at hybrids
but the Chinese flesh came ahead in the
tiebreaking one so to mention still
world champion but good actually I had a
great day and this was a very nice
smashing victory for her she's white
again Joanne joon-hee six
okay okay all right guys so so d4 plate
d4 plate Knight f6 c4 e6 93 and d5 so
Corey Akina was happy with the
nimzo-indian defense okay but her phone
and said no no names on Indian defense I
want to go for q g t takes here take
here
take sticks
Bishop before check Bishop d2 Queen
takes T to 22 castles
Bishop c4 Knight d7 all theory castles
b6 rook a d1 we should be seven rook fe1
now he goes rook c8 rook c8 attacking
the bishop I just go back they should be
three
she just went back we should be it so
this is all standard this all has been
played before White has the control of
the center but black position remains to
be very solid and very compact so it's
very hard to break
so after Bishop d3 rook e8 was played
okay and players made a couple of more
useful moves h3 h6 and now all the sort
of the simple useful moves are played
already and here you need to come up
with a plan okay it's not so easy to see
what the plan is here but watch garage
Tina did is she played rookie three I
presume she ate analyze this perhaps for
the World Championship or something else
the point of this move is she wants to
put the Queen only two that way her
eforp on is securely guarded okay and
now she has opportunities to consider
pushing d5 and you see the v e5 idea
soju and jun goes here and now white to
play here after putting this all these
pieces together what is the plan what is
the plan here
now what to do what do you think white
is trying to do in this position what
did Alexandra Gloria Gina trying to do
here because she put everything together
like this but there is a purpose there
is idea that she wants to do it so
what's the plan here for white to try to
break through well but the problem is
your if for pawn will always be hanging
okay
that's problem 95 also could be met by a
move like Knight d7 trading off
yeah once we this is the whole point of
this line is to try to open up you know
break through you know here this this
idea she does is a kind of a typical
idea for this position she sacrifice a
pawn but you get a good outpost for your
knight on f3 and then you have some
strong you know some potential attacking
ideas strong attacking ideas perfect
she takes don't rush don't rush okay
don't you rush here please
five he goes here
ruk differ because he wants to go to he
wants to go to Knight f4 and 96 so the
idea here is to try to prevent that okay
when we do it by playing rock d4 nagas
g6
non-rush don't rush
so what's the idea here 54 g6 now we
have to improve our queen correct queen
only - it's not helping our attack not
helping to conduct the attack here so
you need to improve the position of that
queen d3 or we also don't want Roxy one
check and stuff you know so we want to
stop that
absolutely now he goes here
the night h2 she wants to bring the
Knight to g4 to attack the h6 punt and
target the weak pawn weak square on f6
okay now Queen c5 played by juban June
what is she trying to do what black is
dreaming about in this position what is
blocks dreaming here
Quincy one swap the Queen's after board
that's what he's trying to do she's
trying to do okay swap the Queen said if
Queens come off the board block is happy
okay because no I'm not he's not gonna
get she's not gonna get made it so are
we gonna allow that to happen are we
gonna do that oh of course not of course
we're not gonna let that happen
how how're we gonna try to prevent that
and still keep our attacking prospects
here
look back to e1 okay Quincy three
proposing the exchange you know trying
to force the exchange what are we going
to do
what do you do
you
absolutely that's your only move
otherwise you're gonna have to force the
trade routes so queen d1 and now Luke
ec8
this perhaps was maybe a little
questionable you know because that gives
an opportunity for Gauri Akina to do
what she had planned to do so I'm not
sure if this is maybe maybe this is the
moment where Joe and Jun went in
accurately a little bit but on the other
hand it's hard it's hard to see you know
what to do so paint here and now don't
rush please don't rush
you have 94 but you have another idea
here that is very strong which okay I'm
gonna give you some time to think I
don't want to give you more hints I need
you to play like the Russian superstars
break another pawn break needed here
look at that
shaky King side that shady King side
here I need a break I need a break for
you guys now Knight f6 comes back to
defend Quincy one here Queen e2 I mean
not to mention I can take on f7 check
and f7 check I don't know what you're
gonna do because you cannot take with
the rook I take one so you wanna take
with the King I have Queen f3 check
so if six is that breakthrough move that
you need okay and now I went here and
now another excellent move here from
white knight on f6 is always a good
defender it's always defending
controlling and here you have a way to
neutralize neutralize that defender okay
yeah
Nagas King g7
now what do we do he had to go into sin
because g6 was very difficult so what
should we do what do we do
what should we do what do we do
just take just take now she takes back
the rock f7 now the King position is
very weak and now go for it go for the
attack yesh the position has been
weakened shaken now what are we gonna do
will be one couldn t one maybe goes
Queen f6 not yet not yet bring some more
pieces in the game first bring some more
forces into the attack which piece we
can try to bring in with power correct
g5 he goes though he's not gonna give up
now treating queen c1 trading the
Queen's again black is dreaming about
trading black will be happy to give up a
pawn or two to get into an endgame here
because the King is so vulnerable what
you're gonna do to prevent that what
you're going to do now to prevent that
from happening
Quincy one is a threat a serious threat
exactly check he's checking you now you
go background he's gonna go Quincy one
you know that g3 worked have to check
nice move accurate move needed f4 rocket
force let's not give up material yet
guys we said all the moves pretty much
correct defending and threatening
what are we threatening here Queen h5
attacking h6 attacking the g6 square
yeah absolutely open the diagonal goes
here he's trying to meet Queen h5 with
rook f6 but now White has some Tempest
time to activate that Queen on the one
that has been sitting there for a while
fantastic and now when opponents
position is weakened stretched out there
are so many targets here now make a
target how you gonna make a target here
absolutely h4 absolutely h4 weakening g5
now and covering that shield you know
the shield is the g5 pan you want to
destroy the shield to come up with the
mating ideas fantastic
now h4 queen safai proposing the
exchange again we can exchange winsome
pounds back it's not really what we want
to do no we want to keep the Queens on
the board how your attack is extremely
powerful right now extremely powerful
mm-hmm
25 and now he plays d4 trying to trade
but now tactics work out good for Gary
ah Tina go really now how true when June
realizes if he takes one or two with the
Queen H takes she is just mating she
knew it at this point she's losing how
how she's losing here
correct because if now queen is taken
you have it what you have now in between
G takes f6 check a very powerful
in-between move check double check King
has to move and the game is well yeah
check wins the game
okay so that's the point okay so g5 take
she took back here and now rook takes
check King h8 mate in three basically
now correct cannot step on a G file
because discovery check have to go here
and the move that will end the game and
a powerful win for garage Gina Queen g3
perfect can I go to the H file G file
Queen G structure six Queen g6 mate if
you go to have seven what's the Moline
what's the win here everybody rook h7
YouTube audience perfect and powerful
player I really like this game I think
it was a very very powerful play by
Corey Akina excellent very nice play you
know especially you know going back a
little bit the first 15 or so moves are
all theory so it really showed her well
people her preparation here this has all
been played before this and but this
rookie 3 plan it shows she spent the
time you know she worked really hard her
her coaches to come up with this idea
it's a very deep idea you know you put
it here and then you push basically
black can play d5 but it's always worse
those positions because the past pawn
you know
maybe wendy6 is possible there but now
just this position
then you just go for a very powerful h4
yeah this was just I I think right here
you know perhaps maybe something
something black could have done because
moving the rock away allowing e6 was
tough you know okay very well okay we're
going to look at another example of
color okay the position where the
weaknesses of the squares are very
important you ready
this is the older game by play by
portage okay lie or sport ish this may
be different partitions is f portage but
no all right lock to play in this
position guys again the topic is the
color the weak squares the weak if the
colors are weak you know what are you
going to do here
1975 really it says F port dish right I
don't know
it's a [ __ ] at F port ish 1975 Hungary
alright well this is the position
Ripley versus F portage Hungary Hungary
1975 black to play you need to find a
strongest continuation here yeah it's
different Portrush Ferentz portage
against Zoltan Ripley it's different
deaf different port ish so what is the
idea now here huh furnace portage was a
strong I am and a brother of the
world-class Grandmaster liar portage he
won this game by brutally expanding and
exploiting the weaknesses of a dark
squares in whites position so strong
strong I am fair in sport ish block to
play here what can you do in this
position
yes
blocks dark squares the whites are sorry
its White's darks course let's block to
play here how did he do that how did he
manage to exploit the weaknesses
of course you're down upon down upon
whenever you're down upon you want to
avoid trading Queens especially
opponents position has been weakened
darks words are weak okay
why not what trade Queens we don't want
to trade Queens guys we don't want to
trade quick
okay so you're suggesting 97 correct
choice that's what he played opening up
the bishop possibility of Queenie check
here and attacking that dark square
bishop okay with the simple idea of
taking the bishop now Bishop d6 plate
the other moves are not that good either
so if you play Bishop a7 just simply
night here and and this actually is
gonna be the game takes is the game here
you'll see what are the other
alternatives here we can discuss here
Bishop d4 is a problem because Knight
goes only five and now 94 is threatened
so you go Knight e 2 and now black has
another strong move here and position
simply collapses after which move
position will collapse here because of
the dark squares
again you he's not connected that's
that's huge plus for you okay so you
could have ideas that you wouldn't have
if he had been canceled and he'd be
absolutely c5 if he takes with the
bishop you have 93 strong move okay and
take on c5 winning if he takes it saying
so he has to take now you just simply
capture 13 Queen h4 devastating check we
couldn't play that the check there
because you had Bishop g3 back so we
take he takes we take
and now
eight three and the simplest thing is
just to take take an a5 he cannot take
it's hanging and if you try to do this
push push push push
basically okay but just very very
powerful position there might be other
alternatives like Bishop c4 as well here
this is a very strong position for you
yeah absolutely just push them all the
way down so because of that blocks
White's best defense here is Bishop d6
which was played now the idea as
mentioned Knight e5 threating Knight C
for now so black has no choice if he
takes Bishop e5 this is bad also so has
to take and now what to do here don't
rush don't rush this is key moment okay
93 check is a move but you need to try
to disrupt white's coordination okay how
how you're going to disrupt that
coordination okay
how you're going to disrupt that
coordination
it should take something well I don't
think we want to sacrifice that much I
mean we already sack the exchange so
let's see let's recover the Liberty now
let's recover a little bit material
perfect
disrupting the coordination he cannot
play Queen F 290 teacher so he has to
working f11 more check right
now if he plays King g1 which is bad you
know I mean it's you can just take rook
b8
and there's just a very strong
compensation here okay 1393 Bishop d4
and everything so so that's why he
played the night
II - now you go to expiate rook d1 and
now strong move needed
correct
threaten queen of to mate
now he goes here
so this queen is the problem now it's
just defending everything what can you
do is there another way for you to try
to disrupt this perfect queen d4 he
couldn't play a four because neither
four obviously what do we do now perfect
Queen b6 and now you need to do what you
need to do what here exactly and now you
look at the Queen is guarding the roof
which is huge
okay for you yeah now trotting queen of
sou goes nine three three and now
and now this cover check but what's the
correct discover check there are many of
them here
well you want to win the rook right
night
yep if it goes 3-1 you go rook t1 okay
and the game is over got it any
questions
fantastic wind by Ference portage okay
very powerful display of how to punish
the opponent for weakening his dark
squares you see it guys
dominating victory here let's look at it
again once again for everybody to see it
it started out right here if you're just
joining us on YouTube so you can see the
follow up 97 Bishop goes back here or
Bishop d6 that's the same thing 95
threatening 94 have to take it Knight
the Queen h4 check Bishop c4 and only
now taking back threatening 93 ideas and
now destruct with this attack cannot
take the picture because F 2 square
needs to be covered because of the
mating ideas has to go here c5
disconnecting the Queen from the F 2
square Queen F 2 can only be prevented
by 93 and now Knight B to check winning
the rope there is another idea route d3
but this is just this just looks too
much you know this just looks too much
once again King in the middle on Castle
weak dark squares all these things
together it's a winning situation for
black very good excellent very he made
his brother very proud his brother was
like oh ok guys we're going to do one
more example okay
and this example it's gonna be the game
of Garry Kasparov against a very famous
opponent Nigel short okay so
let me set this up for you
all right
why to play and win here so clearly we
see some problems around the light
squares so here we're talking about the
light squares okay the light squares are
weakened
how did Kasparov manage to win this game
with a very precise play against Nigel
short Brussels Belgium 1986 not sure
which tournament was this but it's
Brussels
why to play and win
I think the black Bishop was a bit
overprotective
correct
light squares are the issue here okay
light squares are the big issue in this
game
we could try to progress that mission
so what's the move here a little bit
better a little bit better something you
can do here
look the idea is this night you know
Knight e4 you got to get the knight into
the game you're not going to be able to
win this you need the night okay so
Knight comes in with the tempo if he
takes you have Queenie for check it's
fantastic then Bishop c2 and just made
him on h7 or check check g6 is bad also
Bishop Bishop f7 okay so he cannot do
that so he took on e7 and now it's
amazing play because it's not so trivial
here
it's amazing display of technique here
we see next two moves are very very
impressive
what did Kasparov do how did he built up
the pressure
thank you like correct no negative six
doesn't do much but we didn't amplify it
somehow
so what do you want to do
you should do
fantastic fantastic move by Mike perfect
defending the night and getting ready to
pressurize on that light squares print
perfect threatening f4 threatening the
winning f4 move now okay
so blood plays look a fade obviously to
prevent f4 again you won't have a good
discovery it looks like oh I'm gonna win
now but you don't have a good discovery
okay so what are you going to do now
the a4 takes
huh
for 963
g3 preparing H 4 F 4 and H 4 ideas
another strong another nice way you know
to prepare oh sorry there was another
way to play H 4 but it was a little bit
more complicated ok but let me show you
this age 4 here
he takes knight g3 attacking the Queen
and this appears to be winning as well
because now if he goes here check take
wins and if you take with the king then
check wins because you go here or here
you're gonna get made it ok
93
Bishop h4
so it was another anybody played g3
Queen d8 rook ad 1 attacking the Queen
goes here h4 and now he got the bishop
pushback and now what's the idea
now a very special move that wins the
game very special idea
that Gary Kasparov found to win the game
Knight f6 wait don't rush don't rush
Knight f6 is a possibility but something
stronger you have now how you take
advantage of this loose bishops he's got
to loose bishops on e7 on g6
well h5 but maybe he can take with the
Queen I don't know it's tricky
maybe it's far but better what did he
play here huh
you could do that but better look at
this bishop here if you just move your
knight somewhere he's gonna have two
bishops hanging right where can you put
this Knight so he plays here he says
that's fine you can take my bishop now
you got the bishop hanging here bishop
hanging here so you have to take right
no choice now what do you do takes right
now you're threating mate on g7 then
you're ready to come in with this guy as
well on a seventh rank so Nigel short
went here and now
absolutely now attacking this as well he
decided to play Bishop f5 for King him
because he couldn't see anything else he
can try to do here and now what is the
finish
what is the finish yes Wow he did not
play this actually but this works very
impressive very impressive very very
impressive and then I made because part
of actually just played Queen d4 which
you know it's also very good next one
was made you know but not as fancy as a
DEQ's idea yeah yeah Wow very nice very
nice so you see how he did this let's
look at it again okay guys so it started
rough here position is little shaky for
black but he comes in with 94 takes he
goes Bishop C to bring the bishop in
found by Mike Bishop C to move now rook
f8 g3 getting ready to play f4 and h4 he
goes here rook a d1 getting in h4
Knight c3 hitting both bishops here
bishop on g6 pitch 27 he goes here
the rookie 7 attacking g7 and now both
rooks when two rooks come in like this
it's almost always devastating we have
two rooks like this Queen it's you're
not gonna survive this and there's no
example here you know no no difference
here check and queen both in fact queen
d4 is nice but I think Eric's idea works
perfectly fine to Jack then just made I
mean you can insert Queen e5 just to
prolong it but it doesn't work excellent
guys thank you very much for joining
this class I should be back as a
grandmaster in residence in a few months
so this was fun couple of weeks doing
some weed you know lectures and for our
YouTube channel so stay tuned for some
more upcoming videos thank you for
joining us
you
[Music]